hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in Thomas aquinas's sumatelogia Prima
pars question two article 3 we get the
famous five ways to prove or to argue to
or show God's existence to somebody who
is inquiring about this and these are
all we could say metaphysical arguments
that take their their beginning
in some sort of experience that we have
and then work their way backwards and
the first was based on
motion
um causality in general you could say
the second zeros in a bit more on what
Thomas and other people of his time who
are aristotelians would call efficient
causality so we have to do a little bit
of ground setting here Aristotle very
famously
distinguished four different types of
causes four answers to the question why
and so one of these is what we typically
think of as cause and effect today and
that's efficient causality that is the
type of cause that produces an effect
that brings it into being right and now
it could bring it into being completely
sort of like you might think about an
artificer working on an artifact right
or parents generating their children
things along those lines fire
causing the the piece of wood to burn
and combust and turn into something else
making Ash for example
but there's other types of causality at
play as well and we want to recognize
them and also sort of put them aside so
there's the material cause of things
what it is that things are made of which
is an answer to why is it the way it is
you know you think about our human body
right uh there's all sorts of answers to
well why does the blood work the way it
does what causes it to circulate as it
does and you could say well part of the
answer is the heart pumps right and what
causes the heart to pump well the brain
is sending signals to that message but
you could also say that the blood itself
can flow because it's a certain kind of
material it's a liquid with all sorts of
things suspended in it and we don't have
to go too far into that this isn't a
lecture about Aristotelian causality per
se but then there's also the formal
cause and very often when we're thinking
about efficient causality formal and
material causes go together so think
about the famous example of the bronze
statue bronze is the material the statue
itself has a certain form it might be
the famous statue of the Archer that's a
structure that's given to it and it's
given to it not because the bronze
spontaneously forms itself but because
somebody says I want to make this statue
I'm going to do the work I'm going to
efficiently effectively cause this
statue to come in being with a certain
out of a certain material with a certain
form and then there's also the final
cause the why in the sense of what for
what's the purpose what is the goal what
is it tending towards now we're focusing
here in the second proof entirely on
efficient causality
Aquinas says that it's ex razione cause
I efficientus so efficient causality or
the efficient cause ex rathione out of
the nature the intelligible nature of
efficient causality now what what is in
in that intelligible nature you're going
to see this talked about in various sub
parts of this this article right in the
second way part and let's not begin at
the very beginning we'll come back to
that in a second one of the key ideas
is that
a thing
cannot cause itself he tells us we never
observe in venator we never run across
nor is it possible
that something would be the efficient
cause of its very self quote Ali quid
sit that something would be causa
efikians the efficient cause sui ipsius
now that ipsius is an intensifier and
what we're looking at here is that you
know you could say that I'm a cause of
myself in some way you know as a
professor because I chose to go to
college and then graduate school and
then get a job and all that but I didn't
make this thing that I am come into
being I may have modified it through
decisions that I've made actually for
the better and for the worse right some
things are Beyond My Control I'm an you
know middle-aged man as you can tell by
my beard and all of that sort of stuff
my body is slowly transforming but you
know I can I have some measure of
control whether I exercise eat right
right you know get good sleep those
sorts of things
but I don't cause myself as a whole
as a totality
so this is a really important principle
if you've got something that is caused
what we call an effect in Latin Effect 2
is what has been affected right cause
efficients affectus what the efficients
did created if you've got an effect well
then it has to have something else
as it's caused and we can you know trace
this out quite a ways because something
could be both a effect but also a cause
of something else and we see things now
here's where we begin
arranged into series or orders
of efficient causes
as how Aquinas says this and it tells us
that in venimus in him in istis
sensibilius okay so now this is a little
bit different than the first way where
we did in fact begin with what is
available to the senses uh in sensu
right in that article here
um in istis sensibilius in those things
that we can sense or do sense right we
come across now we don't just come
across a thing we come across an
ordering
of causes and effects
and you know this can be very very
complicated as Thomas tells us the
middle or mediating causes can be plural
they can be singular right so let's take
a really super super simple example that
he gave in the previous uh thing so if
we have a stick
and the stick is in a hand right and the
stick is used to push something you know
let's think about billiard balls for
example we've got a pool stick we hit
something we put it into motion and then
it hits something else right these are
causes now we're interested primarily in
causes that produce don't just change
but produce something and so we actually
do observe this Thomas Aquinas says in
the sensible world we don't just observe
one thing and then another thing we
observe that the one thing comes from or
is produced by the other thing and then
it is produced by something else in turn
so we've got the last thing the effect
the ultimate the end of the series right
which may not actually be the total end
of the series but let's say that for the
purposes of this proof it is and then we
have uh you know causation efficient
causation and the middle cause which is
both a cause and effect he calls that
the medium right and then we have an
earlier cause and in fact the premium in
this case and it's not the premium in
the full sense like capital P premum
first that we're going to get to
eventually but it's first in that order
right and there's lots of things in the
world that we observe partly processes
and then there's other stuff going on
and here's where we start to make the
move into the metaphysical
so we transfer this idea
to a whole bunch of causes because we
know that everything has to have
causes all the things that we can
observe have causes right it's not
possible for something to be the cause
of itself
so beyond the things that we do in fact
observe through our senses
there have to be other causes and now
the question that he raises in this
particular way is the same as in the
first way can the series go back to
Infinity can it
in infinitum right now there's a slight
change of language here
but it's basically the same thing and
the answer is no it cannot
you can't go back endlessly and why not
well for the same reason again as in the
first cause or the first way a lot of
connections between these isn't there
so why not well if you don't have some
sort of absolutely first efficient cause
Prima causa efficients something to make
things come into being well then you
don't get the other things in the series
and we can we can see this in our
ordinary life if you take away as Thomas
says the first cause in the series then
the middle cause doesn't happen and the
final effect doesn't happen right so
we're sort of extrapolating from what we
see in our own experience and adding in
some metaphysical principles some
assumptions that are being made and then
saying well there has to be a first
cause because no first cause nothing
else happens however we do know that
things happen because we see it we
experience it we take it for granted you
might say it's part of our very way of
being in the world to note not just
individual things but the causal
connections between them so since that
is the case
he concludes well there must in fact be
a first efficient cause Prima causa
efikians and then he has the very famous
uh saying uh that everyone gives the
name God to this and notice that it's a
slightly different formula right in the
first proof it was Hulk omnis
intelligentam everybody understands this
to be God this is a little bit
um
stronger
omnes
everybody gives the name literally of
God to this first cause
so you know he's concluding this isn't
everything that God is for Thomas
Aquinas he's not just an efficient cause
of everything through this vast chain of
causality but this is indeed something
that we can say about God and we can say
according to Thomas Aquinas that this
God understood in this way must of
necessity exist or we wouldn't have all
of these sense experiences of orders of
efficient causality